[Music]
look at this person a little Graham had
to do it
should he had to cam Redis making a
right a nice little steal attempt and
obviously getting the foul on she he two
more opportunities plus this one
Goldwater about that is lose the
confidence of Cruiser they're getting
nothing in that Lane nice kick
[Music]
plenty of people at the rim so that's a
good tape had missed their last 11
threes before that ones reddish and he's
too talented he is so talented just want
to contain a couple of dribbles against
these quick guys that's radish Wow
Brenda's relishing yeah I think he might
have hurt himself there when he landed
might have landed on the Laurier's foot
there what handle things in the corner
here for the Blue Devils touch he'll be
already says get that out of here here's
Rhenish fee for this guy you know the
other point to of leaving him in having
that that injury and coming back to the
ACC and in the hands of parent snaps it
ahead Diane Williamson to the paint to
the corner back out to reddish he can
fire from here knocks it down perimeter
guys knocking it in red is showing that
beautiful form on their three pleasure
those pins except for work but DeLaurier
able to rebound it numbers
when they come they come in waves so
effective so many guys can handle nice
decision near the rim or they can mount
his water president
once again the flash the kick and the
three in that middle the ball gets to
the middle is I on Williamson a great
decision-maker finding the open camp
reddish for the three glory aid not much
of an offensive player so taco Falken
zone things up but ham red is so much
talent getting hot at the right time for
the Blue Devil two-point shot that was
an impressive one to slop it up here
throw it up to it again he's a senior
who will graduate in May in the Dawkins
he waits and lost control of it Duke
comes out with it would have been six
well that could be a game changer that
mistake thing my reddish back down the
water turn of events right there that
was a five-point swing a layup missed
layup missed opportunity
don't settle now
reddish on the board with a three
buh-bye well alternative of forget about
it right there there on the roll might
complain
the two-man game
Renaissance shot he buries it but he is
a nice way of just pulled it off
hesitating stretched 17 points by tilma
the bill with nine rebounds as raddish
tries to flip it over to me then the
basket goes